if you'd like to get scared this weekend  spend some money on this freakling  brothers horror shows open in the  parking lot of the ikea down in the  southwest valley  two new experiences one's called the  men's room the other one's called death  swamp  it's open every day but the fright will  last a lifetime  the sand dollar lounge now the nightmare  on spring mountain you can check out a  spooky cocktail menu now there's  halloween decorations of course they  have live music and costume  incoming costume on certain nights it's  open through monday again another way to  freak yourself out for a full list of  the events check out all the halloween  happenings on eight newsnow dot com just  search halloween